[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
Thanks for coming.
I'm here to introduce
Professor Robin Fleming, who
will be introducing
our speaker today,
because she knows
what he does and knows
him much better than I do.
So without any further ado.
ROBIN FLEMING: So
it's really a pleasure
to be able to introduce
at Google Dominic
Powlesland, who's really
the leading pioneer
and advocate for all things
computing in archeology.
And there are just a
few essential things
you need to know
about Dominic other
than the information
that's on this slide there.
He's the director of
the Landscape Research
Center at York, and
from there, he's
presided over the largest
and most important
excavation in Europe.
And he works on a scale
that really no one else does
at a site called West Heslerton.
West Heslerton is an enormously
complex multi-period chunk
of landscape, and it's produced
over a million artifacts.
And I know that's
one of those numbers
that Google doesn't count
that low, but in archeology
that's a very, very big number.
In his 30 years of dealing
with West Heslerton,
Dominic has pioneered a whole
gamut of digital methods
in archeology, which are now
absolutely standard practice,
including remote
sensing, the collection
integration and analysis of
geospatial data, 3D imaging,
as well as all sorts of
interesting things like the use
of isotopes and DNA.
And the last important thing
to know about Dominic before he
comes up is that
he's been excavating
since he was 11 years old.
And one doesn't get to hear
of an archeology prodigy
very often, and I think
he might be the only one.
[APPLAUSE]
DOMINIC POWLESLAND: Thank
you very much indeed.
I am a landscape
archaeologist, and I
will try as much as possible not
to get nerdy about my subject.
But I've also been involved in
computing for a very long time.
We started using computing in
the field in the very early
1980s, and have been
using handheld computers
for data collection since then.
And amazing enough, I went to
a conference a couple of years
ago in Australia, and
apparently they've
invented this thing called
a mobile phone which
you can record on,
and it's really quick.
I was never really
interested in quick.
My interests are in
having consistent quality
data that allows us to
produce improved analysis.
So most of what we
know about archeology
has been discovered as
a result of serendipity,
chance discovery.
In this particular case of
an Anglo Saxon cemetery,
this is a cemetery from the
fifth to the seventh century
with lots of bling in
it, all sorts of stuff.
And it was discovered
by a man walking a dog.
And he at school had done the
three Rs, archeology reading,
archeology writing, and
archeology arithmetic,
because that's all you
learned in West Heslerton
School in 1952, because the
school teacher was passionately
interested in the past.
And my interest is
really in trying
to understand the human
influence on landscape,
the human response to changes in
landscape-- things like climate
change and what goes on
in the world around us.
And it will be now more
some time in the 1980s, very
early 90s I was interviewed
for a job in the Geography
Department in the university
in the north of England.
And I said what I want to
do is I want to have this--
because I'd already written the
GIS that we still use-- I said
my GIS to be the
whole world, and I
want to be able to go
anywhere in the world,
and I want to be able to map
things like climate change
on the globe.
I didn't get the
job, and some time
after that, some other
bastard keyholded it.
And I'm very, very
grateful, because it
is the most transforming
piece of software.
I do not know a
person who hasn't
looked at their own
house in Google Earth.
It allows us to do
things that we could not
do in any other way.
Well, we can do them other
ways, but actually it
makes things easier.
In terms of communicating
with the world beyond,
making things
easier is important.
I'm interested in the computers
in the service of mankind.
Many years ago in the mid
'80s, I made a BBC television
program, or we had a
series called "Computers
in the Service of Mankind."
And it was a great
pity that somebody
in the BBC at the final moment
changed the title of the series
to "So I Bought a
Computer" because it really
didn't have the same
ring, and it really
wasn't about what I believe in.
I believe that we
use these tools.
They're like really
good pencils.
And we use them to engage
people and encourage
people to become absorbed in
what we do intellectually.
So most often, you'll
see things like this.
This is a dot distribution map.
I [INAUDIBLE] show, that red dot
is the place I'm talking about.
So it's in the
northeast of England.
And dot distribution
maps are very popular,
and I'm sure that
all of you that
are involved in things
like Google Earth
will be happy in
the appreciation
that the bit in between the
dots is not an empty place,
it just happens to be you
don't know anything about it.
So when I first
went to this place--
these are all in kilometers, I
know that's new money for you.
But that's probably about
10 or 11 miles across,
and nine or 10 high.
And that was the known
archeology in this area.
So these are
prehistoric earth works.
They're part of a
major drove way system.
How you got around the
countryside at about 3000
BC is you went along
the tops of hills,
because you'd already
got rid of all the trees.
So you could not only
see the landscape,
but you could be seen in it.
So if someone was feeling
unfriendly towards you,
you would know it.
So I started digging
in this place in 1978.
It started as a
rescue excavation,
a gravel courier was destroying
that Anglo-Saxon cemetery.
And what we found very
quickly was actually
there was archeology that was
buried beneath blown sand that
was unique in Britain.
To have this barrow-- this is
a Bronze Age barrow from about
2,500 BC-- it's older than
that-- that's entirely
buried by blown sand and has not
seen the light in 3,000 years.
So this is very unusual.
Most of these monuments,
somebody who wanted something
from the mantel piece would
have gone in the 19th century
and extracted the contents.
And so this is very rare.
So we have archeology
that's preserved in a way
that we don't generally find.
So that makes it potentially
more intellectually engaging,
and might give us
more information.
This is the best thing you
can do with your clothes on.
Digging, quite
frankly, allows anybody
to be five years old in
terms of their engagement.
And I still get a real buzz when
I pick something up and realize
that somebody hasn't touched
this for 4,000 years,
this piece of flint, or bone
comb, or whatever it is.
There's a real
contact there, and I
don't suppose I will ever
lose that love and things.
I used to have short
shorts and short hair
for a very short time.
This is sometime in
the 1980s I think.
And these were in a
very, very famous--
they're in sort of the bible
of archaeological techniques.
And there I am with my handheld
computer shop, PC 1500.
And why did I go into
all this computing stuff?
Well, because I am chaos.
We used to use bits
of paper to record on.
And once I realized I
was digging a trench that
was 110 meters wide
and 750 meters long--
which is quite a lot of
this troweling stuff--
and it was full of
archeology, I realized
that my abilities to manage
the pile of paper that
just kept rising was appalling.
And I would go and get
out a piece of paper
because it was about something
I was interested in at the time.
Phone would ring, they'd tell me
about this burial or something,
so I'd go find the
paperwork, and then
I'd put it down somewhere.
And then somebody would
ring for something else.
And before no time at all, I
had piles of paper everywhere,
and I couldn't find anything.
And my father was
a civil engineer,
and he gave me a
Wang 2000 computer,
and I taught myself
to program on that.
And we ran it in a sort of
a primitive way, really.
We spent two years
designing a data structure
before we got a computer,
because I really
wanted to be able to ask
every question I would ever
think of this data.
And it's quite critical,
so we have a site, an area,
the concept was a unit
of soil or a feature.
This is not just archaeological.
Any environmental science
could use this structure.
And an object number
was a two-letter code.
So you've got a three-digit
number, a two-letter code,
a five digit number,
a two-letter code.
So 12 characters that
make you unique key
for every single thing
that we found since 1978.
And about two years ago, in a
moment of severe frustration--
because I have so many
different rate arrays in my home
to make sure that
I've got backups
of the backups of the backups
if I ever lose anything--
I typed one of those
numbers into Google
and I immediately got my thing
back at the top of the page.
And that is quite extraordinary.
There is no other
archaeological database
in the world that's
heavily computerate
that would automatically give
you that return straight away.
This is an object,
it's a 3D model.
This is a Bronze Age beaker,
and the beaker people
are to do with the introduction
of bronze in Northern Europe.
They're very significant
in that period in sort
of when agriculture
becomes properly settled,
and they made these fancy pots.
And we know from the pollen
that they contain alcohol.
And it may be that
part of their power
was because they could
control this wonder stuff.
And by 3D modeling it
with very high precision,
I can get schools anywhere
in the world to look at that.
I can send a note to
an academic colleague
and say, oh, it looks like
we've got this white stuff
in the decoration on this.
Would you like me to see
if I can send you a sample,
and you might be
able to analyze it?
So I consider that what
we do in 3D imaging
is creating digital
afterlives for objects.
And SciOp will tell you
that they preserve things
by scanning them.
They do not preserve
them by scanning them,
they make a surface that
pretends that it's preserved.
But we are able to create a
very precise, measurable models
which can be articulated,
and could even be printed,
which get people close to things
that they would not otherwise
be able to do.
So just before Christmas I
did a Chinese oracle bone
at the University
Library in Cambridge,
the oldest piece of
writing they have.
It's 2,500 BC, or thereabouts.
And it was published it
FIZZ.org a few weeks ago,
and within two days
there were 5,000 hits.
So 5,000 different people
looked at this object
from around the world.
Now, this pot would
have never been
seen by the number of people
that have now seen it.
So anyway, there's a bit
about our data structure.
And amazingly enough, that
data structure is still used.
We still use it today.
So this country seems
to have a problem
with people called Donald.
Don't know what it is.
These are the
ramblings of a Donald,
I don't know if any of you
know where this comes from.
Donald Rumsfeld.
That's the one.
"There are known knowns.
There are things we
know that we know.
There are known unknowns."
There is bollocks, basically.
But it actually
does describe what
we do when we try to do
remote sensing quite well,
and I've used it for lots
of remote sensing things.
So I want to very
quickly run through bits
of the aspects of the landscape.
The landscape that we live in is
textured by human interference.
This is a Bronze Age
barrow, and that dodgy thing
was the thing we got
to piss alignment.
Sometimes they
survive beautifully
in the way of these
monuments here.
Other times they're
just in plowed fields,
and we see them due to
differential growth in crops
from planes.
You can see them in
Google Earth as well.
You can see lots of
them in Google Earth.
You can see everything.
But if only you'd make
sure they take the pictures
on the right day.
I had a project with the
BBC about 10 years ago,
and we were going to do a sort
of crowd-- not crowdfunded,
but crowd-data
project-- and I wanted
to get people all
over the country
to take a five kilometer
square and try and find
all the things
that they could see
in the crops in Google Earth.
And it didn't happen.
I understand the idea
has been recently nicked
by somebody from over
here, but I don't mind.
I have lots of ideas.
But it is utterly absorbing.
I have wasted many, many hours
looking through Google Earth
at crop marks.
This one is available
in Google Earth.
I know that.
This is one of my photographs,
but at the same time,
images that were used in
Google Earth were created.
And the thing about Google Earth
as opposed to me flying around
in an airplane is flying around
in airplanes is lots of fun,
but the Google Earth
coverage is contiguous.
And this is why it is important.
It doesn't have any gaps in it.
And that makes it
like nothing else
that we can do in terms
of visualizing landscape,
because we can't do
it any other way.
So it doesn't have eight
centimeter resolution data
very often, which is a pity.
I wish it did.
But with eight
centimeter resolution--
so this is a piece of
a later [INAUDIBLE]
Roman ladder settlement,
we call them.
So if we want to think
about the bigger world,
we do have to get
out of our boxes.
This is my daughter
when she was one.
We had to drink all
the wine to find
a box that's big enough to put
her in while we moved her out
of our room.
And it is that process
of not believing
what you think you know.
Taking on those unknown
known known unknown things
and trying to recycle
your knowledge,
never believe what you think you
believe, because you're wrong.
And so we started a
campaign of trying
to go from looking at
excavations to the much
bigger landscape.
A landscape which of
course we've already seen,
has got nothing in it.
So we've used lots of
different techniques.
This is a GeoEye two
meter monochrome.
And the interesting about
the two meter monochrome,
it's not really two
meter data at all.
It's just been sold
as two meter data,
because these pixels
are very fuzzy.
When you look at
their five meter data,
they're not that fuzzy.
But of course, they're
not really much good
compared to this.
So this is a five
centimeter probably,
and this is the conventional
archaeological air photography.
And so we still have our
place, but fortunately, people
like you are
catching up with us.
And eventually, the
clock in Google--
being able to go through lots of
pictures as we go through time
is very good.
You see a lot more data.
So we also have the problems,
there are bits of landscape
that we can't see.
So what do we do with those?
We do lidar.
So this is a lidar
airborne laser scan
of a piece of the
[INAUDIBLE] where
my wife works on the
archeology, the very
post interesting period,
of the 19th century.
It was one of the
most industrial places
in the world at the time.
It was the first major
iron production site.
And they have a
project, and they're
looking at these
production sites down here.
And the lidar, we can take the
trees away quite effectively.
So we can see through trees and
see the landscape underneath.
And then we can take that
data and we can put it back
onto Google Earth, and we
can replace Google Earth
with our image,
which in this case
is lit from multiple directions.
So we get a better grasp of how
that landscape fits together.
So after a lot of
years, we end up
with a crop mark
distribution like this.
So all this stuff.
This is the same map,
and this is showing you
all the things we found
through our photography.
And it has problems,
because it there's
holes all over the
place-- there are gaps.
Because our air
photography is responding
to ground conditions
which are variable,
to climate conditions
to crops that are grown
or may not be in fields,
so you can't go out and
go flying for a week
and find everything
that's there.
This is the accumulated effect
of flying from 1979 to 1996.
So lots of flying.
But what we can do is we can
introduce multiple techniques.
So this is an eight
centimeter, and it
is an oblique photograph.
This is where I had
to cut the wheel out.
The wheel looks really
boring in the image.
And this was because I had
to hang out of the plane
in order to get the photograph,
and so the wheel's in the way.
And these things here, this
is a Neolithic long barrow,
so about 3,500 BC.
This is a Bronze Age round
barrow, about to 2,500 BC.
And these square things are
Iron Age burials and monuments
from about 500 BC to 300 BC.
And in this field here it
looks like it's diseased
because there are thousands
of dead people planted
in holes in the ground.
If we try an alternative
method, in this case
a geomagnetic method, we
find different results.
And in fact, if we use
lots of different methods
and we keep going
back, each one of them
produces its own results.
So one is just not everything.
We have to find ways of using
all these different techniques
and joining them together.
So while we were looking
at the landscape--
this is the cemetery
where we started.
We then dug this
little hole, which
is 500 meters from
one end to the other.
Which, if you're troweling,
is a very, very big trench.
Now most archaeologist
do what we call
blanket coverage, no trenches
bigger than a blanket.
We go for 100 meter squares and
we join them all up together,
because the only sample
that's really worth looking at
is 100%.
And there's a reason for
this, because if we only
look at little percentages of
things we don't understand,
we're not going to
understand them.
And we've had to develop
quite novel techniques
to deal with the data.
So this is my own GIS.
This is a stratigraphic diagram.
This shows this the sequence
of soil deposits in layers
as you go through the site.
This one's on top of that one.
And if it's on top of something,
the thing underneath it
should be earlier, unless it's
in a stream, in which case
it might be upside down.
But the laws of
superimposition are
fundamental to the
way we see archeology.
But when you've got 30,000 units
of soil, handling all of that's
quite difficult. So this is
tied to the drawing over here.
The dots are all finds.
And we can work our way up
and down through this diagram,
showing the sequence at which
these different features occur
and the different events happen.
It's a bit like using the
time slider in Google Earth.
And so Google
Earth, is it useful?
Yeah, I think it
probably is, actually.
So this is the archive from
that excavation in Google Earth.
And hopefully this will work.
This is one of these features.
It doesn't matter what it is.
It's a cavity floor building
in a sixth century settlement.
That's the plan.
As archaeologists, we
also draw the sections.
So there's the cross
sections through the feature.
The feature has
spatial integrity
with the material inside it.
Those are all the finds.
The green things are
objects, the brown things
are animal bones.
This one only had
5,500 objects in it.
There's some basic
stats in here.
I was saying earlier
at lunch that I
tried something else
in Google search today
and it didn't work, so I'd
love you to solve my problem.
You don't have a function in
there to say I want to search,
but can I just search all
the tables that's published.
Because if you did that, getting
to data would be really easy.
Because the billions HTML tables
that are out there archived
all over the world aren't hit
by the Google search engine.
Whereas if your search engine
said right, I can see this
is a table, because
I can read HTML.
Let me look in the table.
Because Google's ability
to search free text
is unparalleled.
It's clever.
I have to admit it.
But tables are different,
because in tables, you
put structured data.
And if you could
start using Google
to search structured
data, people with my life
would be ruined forever, because
I spend all my time going wow,
I just found this out.
But anyway, I just offer
that as a challenge.
Anyway, there's tables here
and they've got stuff in them.
This is all for one feature.
If I wanted to know whether
any sheep, domestic goose,
deer femurs, that
would be really useful.
But I can't search for that now.
So I shall go back
to the narrative.
There is no other archaeological
archive like this in the world.
Every single unit of soil
and every single object
and every single
drawing is represented
in our archive, all in HTML.
The GIS that we use generates
these pages automatically.
You just press go.
And there's a bit
of fiddling around
with some of the scanning of
the drawings, but most of it
is done directly,
computationally.
So we found out
from our photography
that we have lots of gaps.
We then found out that if
we use magnetic techniques,
we can see different things,
and we can see lots of things.
So this is part of a
12 square mile survey
in which we've collected data
to make mere ten sets a meter
intervals for about half of it.
And it was, until very
recently, the largest
archaeological geophysical
survey in the world.
Colleagues of mine in Vienna
who have many, many more toys
and lots of people have just
made one just a bit bigger.
But it doesn't have
this much stuff in it.
So that's looking at 11,
12 kilometers along a road,
and that's about a third
of our total survey.
And what it does is it
takes this landscape that
was formerly empty, and
it has the highest density
of archeology of any
landscape in the world.
Which of course isn't true.
It has the highest density
of observed archeology.
The rest of the world
hasn't yet been observed.
Now, the problem
with all archeology
is that it's all very well
having it, but it's not safe.
And so this thing here--
you see where my mouse is?
Yeah.
That thing there is a plow mark.
So the bottom of the
plow mark is down here
where this two meter red and
white stick ranging rod is,
and that sat on top
of a load of ash.
This is a seventh century
cavity floor building,
and it's filled with ash.
It's filled with the ash
from 10,000 tons of grade
processing.
It's very important
in historical terms.
But for what I'm
talking about today,
the problem here is that the
next time this field is plowed,
we will probably lose
all that archeology.
Because the next time they'll
plow at closer spacing,
and that 15 centimeters of
the past will disappear.
Now, if that happens to
include a prehistoric house
with a preserved floor
because it's under blown sand,
then we're losing
something which we don't
have anywhere else in Britain.
So this is quite critical.
So what the hell can we
do with all that data?
So this is another application
using the Google Earth plugin.
And I know you now
have better toys,
but I haven't had time to
rewrite all of this stuff,
and I probably won't
because it works.
And we put that big survey in
using the Google Earth plugin,
and this is it.
And it contains a whole
range of other data.
So this is a survey giving
us the depth of blown sand
on top of the archeology.
And it's then colored
according to preservation.
There's all sorts
of short words I
used to describe the bits that
were in red, but I won't today.
The bits in blue are
the very best preserved.
Now, it's not important
necessarily that this
is archaeological data.
This is chronological
data about a landscape.
And I'm now going to
attempt the ridiculous.
So there's a piece of landscape.
If I want to see that
gradient with the data,
I can put that on the top.
This is not normally
in public open access
at the moment, because
this is a treasure hunter's
guide to my landscape.
And they won't let
me store landmines,
so we don't put
out the thing that
allows them to precisely know
into which bit of which field
they should go.
And that's not because I
don't believe everybody
should have the information.
It's just we have to develop
a strategy to look after it.
And part of that strategy I
will probably talk about later.
And we can put the blown
sand over the top of that
in a transparent
layer, and we can
start to see the correlation
with those bits of archeology
that are underneath
the blown sand.
And that shows us those
bits of this archeology that
should be best preserved
and those bits that
are least well preserved.
Now, this one doesn't
have the map behind it
because I replaced
it with a model.
And the reason for that is it
hides the individual fields.
And what we've then done
is something which I
think is probably quite novel.
So this takes a while
to load because it's
hundreds of megabytes.
But one of the great things
about the plugin-- and I
don't know who in Google
is responsible for this,
but whoever it is give
them a big hug from me.
Because they did
something really
clever when they included time.
Because we human beings are
not very good about time,
and archaeologists and
historians are crap at it.
We think that time
happens at points,
and then it moves onto another
point and another point.
But actually, it's not.
It's a whole load of
things that bunch together,
they're all doing things
at different speeds
and different things
are happening.
So what I wanted to be
able to represent-- because
in landscape, the
landscape we live in
is an accumulation of
different things over time.
Not very many people in this
room have bought a house
and decided it was 50 meters
in the wrong position,
I'm just going to move it.
Or your gardens in
the wrong place.
If you're very wealthy, you
might buy another bit of land
and have a bigger garden,
but you wouldn't necessarily
move a road because it
was not a nice road.
I don't like that road,
let's move it 50 yards.
So we are landscapers of
accumulation over time.
So what we did with
this is that we
use this clock
thing which allows
you to animate through time.
But it does a bit more than
that, because each one of these
features-- each
one's been coded,
and there's all the GIS
stuff in the background.
And you've done
something to this,
and I don't know what it is.
Because for years,
what this did--
and when I went to see Google in
California for the first time--
these clicked on
things that give you
information with flash, and we
couldn't find how to stop it.
But it's obviously working
now, and I'm very pleased.
So we give every single
one of these features--
there's about 35,000 of them in
here-- a time when it starts,
a time when it
theoretically ends,
and a time when it's
still happening.
And it's that still happening
that's very important.
So these prehistoric monuments,
the barrows, the burial mounds,
they might be being used from
3000 to 2000 BC, or 3500 1800.
But at 1800 they don't
stop being there.
They're a fundamental part of
that landscape until about 1750
AD.
And so we need ways in
which we can articulate.
And we're able to do this.
And if I'd had a lot more
time and a job to do it,
what we would have
done, we would have done
this dynamically on the fly.
But we don't.
The time is hard-coded in.
So we have a
database behind this,
but it doesn't change
when I do this.
This is all done
in HTML and KML.
And what it does is it
draws everything twice.
And it draws it from the
first date to the end date,
and then it draws it in gray
form the end date to the still
there.
But this articulates
the landscape
in a way which is much more
honest and much more real.
And this is quite
important if you
want to deal with people
who aren't archaeologists,
and you'd like them
to understand what's
going on in the landscape.
So all this green stuff,
this is our time scale.
So the green stuff is
the Iron Age of Roman,
if you want to have
a handle over it.
The blue stuff is
earlier, it's Bronze Age.
And somewhere or other
some orange, if I move out.
Oh, here's some orange.
These are Anglo-Saxon.
So this OD covers
about 9000 years.
I cover the bit
from about 15,000 BS
to 1,000 AD, after
which it becomes
a post-Interesting period.
But we don't need
to worry about that.
But this provides us with
a mechanism of distributing
knowledge, not just data.
So I can go out into this.
This landscape looks pretty
boring at the moment.
You don't see this when
you're walking around in it.
And fortunately, it is also
uniquely well preserved.
So all this stuff, this
underblown sand here
is about to have its future
terminated, I have a feeling.
So three weeks ago or
thereabouts-- the 4th of April,
it was in The Guardian.
So "Entire Yorkshire village
could be yours for 20 million."
Google like a research
center in Britain
where you could have away
weeks and you could go and do
environmental and spatial
research in a 27-bedroom house.
They don't mention it has a
bit of a hole in the roof.
This is for us a real crisis,
because this particular estate
has not been doing deep
plowing for the last 50 years.
So all that archeology is
currently well-preserved.
And if it just goes to the
most rapid turnaround, biggest
return farmer, it will
all get destroyed.
And the reality is, we want to
take about 200 or 300 hectares
out of this and create
an archaeological and
environmental research park.
We want to plant that geophysics
in different organic herbs,
which will actually
make their own income.
The rest of the estate will
actually be self-sustaining.
I think this is
a brilliant idea.
I've been working on an idea
for that for some years,
and it's come up for
sale a bit too soon.
I'm looking, but I haven't
got 20 million this week.
But I think it would be a
really good thing for somebody.
So if we don't do that, well,
say goodbye to the past,
I mean.
Not necessarily, because we
will be able to get knowledge
from those areas.
And we will be able
to distribute it.
But of course, we won't
be able to distribute it
without the tools
that you produce.
So I know this hasn't
all been about computing,
and I would like to tell you
about all the other computing
stuff we've done.
So one of the things I was
talking about in Harvard
yesterday was it's something you
could also do in Google Earth.
A lot of stuff that
we do in real science
is all about probabilities.
And so we use these things
called radio carbon dates.
So all of you people
are radioactive.
And sadly, you're not very
good from a trace element
point of view.
The Americans are much worse
in terms of trace elements
than people in Britain,
because you've had supermarkets
for much longer.
So the oxygen,
led, and strontium
isotopes that you eat and go
into your bones and your teeth,
we can use those to source
where people lived in the past,
broadly.
And in fact, most of it they
get from the drinking water.
But my children all come from
Lidl, or Tesco, or Waitrose,
if we get better off.
But I'm old enough to have
come from East Anglia.
But radio carbon
dating, and we're all
filled with radio carbon.
When we die, that radio
carbon starts to decay,
and every 5,473 years, it
reduces to half that amount.
So that's how we date things.
But of course, it's a
precise imprecise science.
We use lots of
Bayesian statistics
to improve the return,
but the reality
is that it then produces
very silly diagrams, which
most people can't understand.
And so we've developed a method
of reading the probabilities.
So when you calculate your
date, they output file
includes a probability
for every single year
that it could conceivably
be in your date.
So that might be a span of
300 years or 1000 years,
depending where you are.
For this period, it's usually a
span of about 150 to 200 years.
And it always comes
out 95% probability.
But the 95% probability
is not for bump number
one or two or three,
it's any one of those.
So we then read in
that information,
we hold that all
in the giant table.
And then as you
articulate the data,
it then maps those with
different densities.
And those densities
reflect the probabilities.
And then you get
to use this thing.
The contents in here.
These two things are really
good spatial data analysis,
and the bit inside
does the real work.
And if you can actually look
at these aspects of probability
reflected in brightness, you
see an entirely different world.
And it's something I
would quite like to see.
If we could do that
in Google Earth,
I'd be delighted, because
I'm a little surprised
that any other GIS
exists anymore.
I think a few more
tools on top of Google
Earth, you would have--
the world is your
[? welk, ?] as they say.
It's almost there.
You can import stuff,
but actually, you
could do all those
things that Esri
does without any trouble
at all, with a relatively
small programming load.
And I appreciate Google Earth
is not the big money maker.
But I wonder how many
Google users there
would be in the world had it
not been for Google Earth.
Because people that
are not computerate
go first to Google
Earth because they
want to see what their
house looks like.
They don't go and
do a Google search.
My children come home
from school and say daddy,
can we Google it?
Can we go Google it?
Yes, of course you can.
But that's because they
live in a house that's
wall to wall
computers and people
that write software and stuff.
But I live in a remote
village, and I've
watched the profile of
computer consumption,
and it goes Google Earth is
much sooner than using a Google
search.
Eventually, I'm sure
it will be different.
When my children are
grown up the world
will be completely
different because they're
growing up with this stuff.
But certainly my generation.
I know people that still don't
know which is the on bottom,
and they don't have wacky
phones and the rest of it.
So I appeal for
two things, really.
I need help.
This landscape needs help.
But also, I think the
beauty of applied computing
is that we can properly
engage a global public.
And I think that's a
moral responsibility.
And I feel that it's
a moral responsibility
for this archeology.
I've been running this
project-- I dreamed up
the project in 1978
and 1979, and I've
been working on it since then.
I have in between-- I've
had all sorts of nice titles
and been the field
archaeologist in residence
in the delightful
town of Cambridge.
But actually, I'm still
doing this bloody job.
It would be nice to
have a job, because I'm
a self-employed unemployed
archaeologist at the moment.
But if it was worth
doing, it's only worth
doing if it gets out
there to other people.
And you are the people that
deliver the tools that do that.
And I am extremely grateful.
I had to write an email
to someone the other day,
and it said-- oh,
it was somebody
that came to one of my lectures
at Harvard who is a historian
and knows all about
monastic stuff.
And he hadn't been
able to stay there.
He wrote and said thank you
very much, all that stuff.
But I really wanted to
ask you about Yeading
[INAUDIBLE] Priory, which
is where I used to live.
And I said of course in
1980 when I was first
trying to find out about this
particular ancient monument,
I looked it up and the only
nun I found anything about
was not the nun he
was interested in.
It was a nun that became
pregnant in the 15th century
and caused lots of trouble.
So there's loads and loads
of medieval documents
about this particular nun.
Of course, now-- we didn't
have the internet then.
You had physical
books and libraries
which were 50 miles away.
So it is a transformed
world thanks to Google.
We're able to do things that
we could not do any other way.
But again, it's this
thing about serving.
You're serving the dinner,
the intellectual food
of the future.
So I thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
If you have any questions.
AUDIENCE: So there's a little
bit of-- for your own time
investment and people
working on a project,
there's a bit of
how do you balance
the time you spend like data
collection versus organizing
your data versus actually trying
to get insights into your data?
DOMINIC POWLESLAND: I think
that's a very good question.
So first of all,
the reason that we
have run the most computerate
archaeological project
in the world is because
I'm the director.
And I taught myself to
program, and I wrote the GIS
because it was necessary.
So I used to do six
hours a night for years,
and there's about 60,000
lines of code in the GIS.
It does things you can't
do with any other software.
We still use it.
So I was a serious workaholic.
I didn't have children then.
I was just tired all the time.
So I'd spend the day digging
and the night writing software.
But nowadays, that's all there.
But everything is from the word
go, every bit of field work
that we do, the
structure underlies it.
So all the people that work
with me are used to using it.
So for instance, if we
3D a model in excavation,
and we've done a lot of really
serious research on this,
people say oh,
this is fantastic.
It's really quick.
Well, it is quick,
and we can produce
a record that is unparalleled.
I may be able to bring one up.
This gives us an insight into
what we're busily destroying
as field archaeologists that
we cannot do any other way,
because we cannot draw to the
resolution that we get from
a digital model.
This is a dead
person who could not
be retrieved from the ground,
because the bones were
too fragile.
And we're able to
get a 3D record.
We could not draw
with a pen and paper
very well, because it's in
the bottom of this deep hole.
But-- and this may not be
the best model of them all.
And there's lots of models
of this particular body.
But we're able to
model to the degree
that we can see underneath
the measuring stick.
And once that's got
it's final texture on--
So I could then go and do that.
We can take the photographs
in the afternoon,
we can process it
overnight, we can
print it to scale as an auto
image in the morning on a piece
of waterproof paper
with waterproof ink,
and I can go out with the person
that dug it and say right,
now tell me all about it.
We then write those notes
on that piece of paper,
and those are transposed
into the computer.
The one place we would
write on the bit of paper,
because I want them
with the image.
Now, we could not do
that any other way.
We have insights
into this that we
don't get from anything else.
The logical extension
of that approach
is in this model, which has
all these numbers all over it.
So these are all the context
numbers, the units of soil
that have been excavated, and we
can go around and look at that.
If we were to draw
that by hand, it
would have taken a long time.
And my view of what
we do as excavators,
it's a conversation
with the ground.
So we are faced by
this big pile of data
which is soil that
has stuff in it,
and that conversation is
how we try and understand
it and interpret it.
If I can take somebody out
and sit on the ground in front
of it, and say right, we've
got this image, oh look,
I hadn't noticed that,
what's going on there?
It's a whole new
level of information,
and the bizarrest
thing in the world.
So these are made using
digital photogrametry.
And you take lots
of pictures, you
use Agisoft PhotoScan
Pro to process them,
and it will create the 3D model.
But what I had no idea about
when we started doing this--
I've been doing this for
quite a few years now.
So this is a small trench.
This thing here where the
hand this is a Palisade slot.
It's the defensive
wall that was thrown up
when the Scotts trashed
the English in 1300
something or other.
Edward Longshanks ran
away, leaving his army
to be slaughtered
at this hill fort.
And this is a very
late re-defense.
And this is a Bronze Age-- about
1,000 BC-- timber fence that's
part of the rampart.
If I go and look at
this from the outside,
I see something different.
And this is to do with
human perception and acuity.
So when I look at the section
from one side, the stones that
come towards me
from the other side,
they have an increased
ocular presence.
When I turn it
around, the stones
that have been knocked
out of the site
are replacing that
ocular presence.
So we see stuff in stone
holes which haven't
been scraped with a trowel.
So my view is that we
don't have any option.
If we don't start using these
techniques, we are stuffed.
The problem we
have is archiving.
That is probably the
biggest problem of all,
how do you archive
all this stuff?
And very fortunately,
the wonderful university
of Cambridge have what
they call the DSpace, which
is their infinite archive.
And they have offered
to take all of our data.
We offered it to
SCI-Arc, they wanted
to charge us lots of money,
which didn't seem quite fair,
really.
But Cambridge has said
they will take it all on.
And that will give it a future.
And I'm also a big believer
in things with printing.
The biggest problem in
the world for archiving
is digital photography.
I bet at least
one of you has got
a phone that takes photographs.
And you use it, and
you take pictures.
And when you lose your phone,
you lose those pictures
if you haven't put them
on your Google space
or wherever it happens to be.
These spaces are all
very well, but when
you join them and you
put things on them,
they're suddenly
each a hard disk.
I had no idea.
I thought they were out there.
So digital photography is an
absolute potential crisis.
So our view is we take
those best archive pictures
and we print them on
archival paper very small,
because they could
be scanned in again
in the future, if the
digital copy disappears.
So it's a strategic part
of all our planning.
We have to have that sorted
before we go and dig the hole.
You can't sort of go and start
a thing and half way through,
I just need to go back and-- oh,
I have just destroyed that bit.
So archaeological excavation,
every single experiment
is unique.
It's an un-repeatable
experiment.
So that landscape with it's
blown sand and all that stuff
underneath it, once
it's gone, that's
4,500 years of the past
of the north of England
that will never come back.
So there is a
responsibility driving all
this insane computing, really.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: I think
it does, thanks.
AUDIENCE: So looking
at the 3D images,
I was curious what process you
go through to generate that--
the vase and then this.
DOMINIC POWLESLAND: So the
pots are quite difficult,
because it's got the inside
and the outside in only one go.
So the idea in essence,
we use a piece of software
called Agisoft
PhotoScan, which is
written by some Russian people.
And it is superb.
Of all the things that do
this, it's by far the best,
and I've tried them all.
So when we do a lot of
the 3D modeling ones,
I will describe the technique
in a paper like this.
A fat man.
So this shows you the
photographic approach.
And then when we use
structure for motion,
which is the mathematics
behind how you calculate
where the camera
is, but basically
it's looking and using
bundle adjustment
to identify groups
of pixels that
have a recognizable
contrast signature from one
to the other.
So it goes through
each image and tries
to match up those signatures.
And it will do it basically
to a very crude point cloud,
and then it works out
where that projects
the positions of the
cameras that you see here.
From that, it then
reverses the process
to try and improve the position
of the camera precision
by reversing it back
onto the object.
And when you've got
through that process,
you then triangulate
it to get a tin model.
But to get inside that pot, just
take hundreds of photographs.
And you have to mask
them all as well,
because depth of field
for a small object
is really quite problematic.
So if you read an article
that says all you need
is a rubbish camera,
don't believe a word.
You need a good camera
and a proper lens.
And you have to be very--
it's like everything we do.
You have to be rigorous.
It's rigorous, boring science.
You do it the proper way,
and you get good results.
And if you don't, you don't.
If you look at this on the web,
all those runes on the body
are all individually
tagged as well.
I think it's had 8,000 or
9,000 people have looked at it.
Now 8,000 or 9,000
people would never
have seen that during its life.
And I'm hoping that
we will eventually
be able to get radio carbon
date for the contents.
But in terms of if you happen
to be a rune geek or you happen
to be in a school, being
able to go and look
at the vessel in this way-- so
there's a little bit of control
you have on the web.
So if I turn this
to high definition,
and then I turn
this to shadeless,
you can say inside
it quite well.
But this is all down to hundreds
and hundreds of pictures,
and having to mask everything
that's out of focus.
So it took about four hours
to do the photography and four
weeks to get the result.
And it wasn't like I sat there
for four weeks working on it.
I have a very heavily
specified Windows PC
with a wacky graphics
card, and I've
got a heavily specified fruit.
And between them, once they've
got the good graphics card,
you can get this stuff
processed quickly.
And it's about having exactly
the right number of pictures.
If you got too many, it
slows it down enormously.
If they're not sharp,
it doesn't work.
So you've got to be rigorous.
But the end result is stunning.
And more people have
seen this than every
would have seen it in its life,
and it's being used in schools.
So I've just done a
project on a stone
cross, Gosforth
in Cumbria, which
is four and a half meters high.
So we have a camera on
a pole which I control
with a phone, 700 photographs.
Most irritatingly,
the north side
of the cross which
is mostly eroded
is away from the sun,
which while you're
trying to photograph it, the
sun is directly in front of you.
The weather was supposed
to be overcast that day,
overcast but blue sky.
And that was done so that two
schools could share this object
and work on it together.
One is an inner
city London school
with a very mixed intake,
and one is a tiny village
school in Cumbria.
And those kids have
had the opportunity
do something they
could never have done.
You know, the Cumbrian kids know
about it, because it's there.
And it's half pagan
and half Christian,
which makes it even better,
because it has stories that
go into multiple directions.
And the great thing
about any sort
of digital futures
and digital afterlives
is that we're not
concerned with one thing.
I was taught by my dad that
you're either a polymath
or you're dead.
I think that wasn't a bad line.
I think everything we
do digitally gives us
the opportunity to engage
new and different people
and to get everything
we can out of one
piece of digital resource.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DOMINIC POWLESLAND: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: What are the
markers along the surface?
DOMINIC POWLESLAND:
Oh, those are stamps.
They're made using the
sawn-off tine of an antler.
And the thing about this
is that as you go around,
what day of the week is it?
He's got a hangover, look.
There's a double impression
in quite a lot of them.
So they're just decoration.
What is very novel
of course is you've
got this line that
goes around the side.
Now, how do you express this in
normal black and white drawing?
So that line starts up
there and comes around here.
It's a spiral that goes--
how do you do that?
Now, the drawings of
this pot look nothing
like this-- the
published drawings of it.
And you can't go and
have a look at it,
because it's in a cupboard
in the British Museum.
And they've got a lot of stuff,
so allowing this to go out
there is I think is brilliant.
But I've got to dig out, we've
got several of these antler
tines from our settlement, which
have got these stamps cut out
of them.
It's just decoration.
[APPLAUSE]